ja wir sehen uns hier in sinzig ihr habt
ja gerade gesagt man sieht natürlich
auch ganz stark diese furchtbare
zerstörung die das wasser die flut diese
riesige welle angerichtet hat hier in
diesem mehrfamilienhaus das wasser stand
das muss man ja vorstellen drei meter
hoch das ist hier von der ahr durch
diese ganze siedlung durch gerecht
durchflossen hat alles mitgenommen hier
unten dem ersten stock sieht man alles
ist zerstört wir haben natürlich auch
die leute gewohnt waren voller angst
konnten sich dann oben in die ersten
stockwerke retten und konnten sich so in
sicherheit bringen so das sind die
schlechten nachrichten die noch
schlechteren wenige tage nach dieser
schrecklichen flut flatterte den mietern
hier eine kündigung ins haus und zwar
mit der begründung das haus sei komplett
sanierungsbedürftig das stimmt wenn man
sich das da unten anguckt das ist alles
kaputt das muss alles fertig gemacht
werden aber im ersten 23 stock kann man
durchaus wohl so jetzt ist der strom
abgestellt worden der eigentümer hat das
wasser abgestellt und es sind noch 22
meter die harren hier aus die sind seit
sechs wochen ohne strom und ohne wasser
was wir gerade gesehen haben und nehmen
wir stehen eben diese mieter die hier
noch aushalten und ich möchte sie
einfach mal fragen wie sie sich so
fühlen frau schlick auf ihre wohnung ist
weggespült ihre mutter wohnt hier oben
im ersten stock sie helfen ihr leben
quasi im dunkeln abend wie ist das ja
das ist nicht einfach und die alleine
kann sie das nicht machen und sie
braucht hilfe und ohne strom ohne wasser
das ist nicht möglich
was machen sie
die muslima kerzen an machen
und die benutzer wasser muss
aufgebrochen die hat benutzt
und das ist nicht einfach und
schön schwierig oben im dritten stock
wohnen sie frau wagner sie haben auch
hier ausgeharrt sind seit sechs wochen
ohne wasser ohne strom sie haben auch
verzweifelt versucht den eigentümer zu
erreichen nichts ist gekommen
die kündigung ist ihnen ins haus
geflattert wie leben sie seit sechs
wochen ich lebe ohne wasser ohne strom
mit kerzen
wassertragen für glätte oder so erhalten
gaskocher
wie auch die mutter mit kerzen abends
was befürchten sie jetzt ich befürchte
ich weiß nicht was ich befürchten sei
aber ich habe angst das ist hier raus
muss und weiß nicht wohin
das problem ist das muss man sagen diese
wohnung sind sozialwohnungen die sind
mit preisgebunden im januar läuft die
mietpreisbindung ab das heißt wenn diese
wohnung oder wenn die mieter raus wären
könnte der eigentümer wenn er sie
sanieren würde diese wohnung zu einem
wesentlich höheren preis dann neu
vermieten das ist so die befürchtung und
neben mir steht der herr schäfer schäfer
sie sind
hauptberuflich becker sie sind aber auch
beim technischen hilfswerk
sie leben hier eigentlich in der wohnung
ums wohnen aber jetzt beim beim thw in
einer lagerhalle haben sie mal versucht
den vermieter den eigentümer zu
erreichen denn hier alles abgestellt hat
ja habe ich bekommen aber nicht also
weder telefon noch e mail und noch zu
sehen bekommt man ihn und weder
anzugehen sagte hans telefon oder bei
ihm keine reaktion was ist das für sie
für ein gefühl sie müssen sich ja
komplett im stich gelassen fühlen sie
versuchen alles was können sie überhaupt
noch machen gar nichts ich kann gar
nichts machen was heißt
ich kann nur abwarten und hoffen
dass doch irgendwann mal
er sich meldet oder doch das was hier
passiert ja also so kann man nichts
machen also
auch wir haben natürlich versucht den
eigentümer ausfindig zu machen er ist im
prinzip untergetaucht das muss man sagen
wir waren bei ihm an der privatadresse
dort haben wir ihnen nicht angetroffen
wir haben ihnen mehrfach versucht
anzurufen wir haben ihn schriftlich
befragt zu der situation dann sind wir
einfach zu sein büro gefahren in
euskirchen und haben versucht ihn dort
zu bekommen
peter hell guten tag von bild tv grüße
sie ich habe eine frage wir suchen den
herrn mal heller wir hätten gerne mit
ihm kurz gesprochen
wissen sie denn wo wir ihn finden können
wenn sie uns in auskunft geben wie die
situation in sinzig ist mit den mietern
die haben ja eine kündigung bekommen
wissen sie denn
haben wir schon gemacht heute bekommt
keine antwort von herrn mag
können sie denn ausrichten dass wir hier
waren
vielen dank danke
also man sieht die verzweifelte
situation nicht nur die mieter haben
versucht ihn zu erreichen wir auch und
auch die stadt die stadt die ist
natürlich aufmerksam geworden aufgrund
dieser katastrophalen zustände und die
hat jetzt dem eigentümer ein
instandsetzungs gebot
aufgezogen das heißt ab morgen läuft die
frist ab morgen müsste er im prinzip
einen plan vorlegen wie er diese wohnung
neben sanieren kann und muss damit die
mieter hier weiter wohnen aber das muss
ist auch wieder befristet und das kann
ewigkeiten dauern also es ist überhaupt
nicht klar wann überhaupt die mieter
hier wieder normal leben können
bitter wie genau wird es denn für die
menschen dann jetzt weitergehen gibt es
das am ende doch noch irgendeine gute
nachricht oder wie es die aussage vor
ort
also in diesen ganzen chaos und in
diesem ganzen trubel und was hier alles
schreckliches passiert ist gibt es noch
so etwas wie einen kleinen
hoffnungsschimmer
wir haben heute morgen mit dem
bürgermeister von sind sich telefoniert
haben ihm noch mal die situation
geschildert er kennt die situation und
er sagt er hat uns versprochen am
telefon die mieter die jetzt hier noch
verblieben sind sollen sich an die stadt
wenden sollen sich an ihn wenden und es
würde wohnraum zur verfügung stehen bis
die wohnung eben hier fertig saniert
sind das sind seine worte und das ist so
etwas wie ein bisschen licht am ende des
tunnels
[Musik]